my name is Markiplier and welcome back
to Amanda the adventure I'll get started
in just a little bit here but obviously
I'm streaming this if you're watching
this in the future then I'm not
streaming this and it definitely isn't
live and you don't need to worry about
trying to talk to me live because if
you're watching this in the future it's
not but if you're watching in this in
the past which is the now of your time
of my time not it's the past of your
time but the now of my time in the now
of our time but it's the past of your
time but if it was in the past for you
then it is the now of me now and you can
respond to me because it is live
does that make sense everybody confused
hello hi welcome to
um Amanda the adventure we're gonna
finish this just like I said I would
just like I said I would but first off
I have to tell you about the brand new
collection from cloakbrand.com if you
pursue the link in the description below
you can go see the new Tactical heat
collection
um
this is one of them uh no joke the these
um pants that we have this time they're
very light uh sweatpants style pants
that's a weird way to talk about pants
uh they're extremely comfortable they're
unbelievably comfortable check them out
cloakbrand.com I'm very happy with this
drop even if it was designed by someone
other than myself but as CEO of cloak I
can uh take credit for it I'm pretty
sure so I take full credit for this drop
and I think everything about it can be
attributed to my genius
um so if you go to cloakbrand.com you'll
definitely see my genius at work it
doesn't really matter you know I'm not
really a big person in my credit so
that's why I don't need to necessarily
have everything with my name on it
but uh you know who is the uh Mastermind
behind all this if you go over there
really is me
hello
cloakbrand.com
it's down there in the description or
you can type it in yourself new drop
check it out extremely comfortable
lightweight very fun uh this might be
the loudest design that we have
um and I'm not wearing it out of
preference because like I said I I may
not have been the the brains behind it
but I I think I'm the brains behind the
overall idea of it
um and therefore even if this isn't
necessarily something that I would make
I'm wearing it out of sheer uh support
of everything
does that make sense am I making sense
to you guys
will I say hi to you if I you agree to
get cloak brand yeah absolutely hi hello
my broken noses
oh my nose is fine it was like
immediately better I don't know what
happened to it but it was just like it
was a one day thing and then it was done
I have no idea like it's it's pretty
much faded away at this point I don't
know what the hell happened like it was
just a very strange thing good morning
from Korea you're watching this in Korea
well thank you thank you so much for
that I gotta go back
can I tell you anything about edge of
sleep uh no I cannot
yeah
hello hello you've never seen one of my
streams well get ready it's um
it's very cohesive and it makes a lot of
sense from start to finish uh and
there's nothing that should be a problem
about anything
right okay good yes good morning from
New Zealand good enough goodness why is
everyone waking up just now
don't you know that uh
early bird gets a worm or something like
that I don't know I'm streaming like
when iron lung yeah eventually
eventually I'm working on it Mom working
on it it's getting there give it a
second good night from Denmark oh well
good night have a good sleep everyone
okay so where we left off with Amanda
the adventurer uh was
I think we have like three tapes and
then a whole slew of random crap to uh
dig through
but if I remember oh God I gotta
remember all the codes oh my God I think
it was guts this one was guts
don't tell me anything I'm not gonna
listen to you
I'm not gonna listen to you I'm not
taking any spoilers I'm not taking any
advice
I'm not taking anything about anything
you can't convince me
okay so which one is this what is a
family I don't know what is a family
nobody knows what a family is okay so I
have this oh
and then uh
I think it was eight
oh what
six
I'm
God you know why my there's nothing in
here
anyway you know why my brain is so big
it's because today I woke up and decided
to wear my cloakbrand.com shirt and
matching pants well I'm not wearing the
matching pants uh technically this shirt
has booty shorts that goes with it
um and I was a little cold today so I
decided not to go with the booty shorts
um however that being said if you guys
go and check it out maybe in the future
I'll model booty shorts for you if
that's what you really want okay
so we have this tape what is family
we've done this this was
I believe
well maybe because I've done all that
maybe it's not going to give me anything
else
okay so we have three tapes let's just
review these just so we can see exactly
what we got
yeah
usually my mom pulls my treat money
well come on Lauren we have a special
surprise for you here's what I have
who's ready for ice cream and cake she's
busy with her best friend
is that show on 24 7. it's like she
didn't even hear me and we need to talk
about some new TV rules
you know what hold on let me try I want
to I want to capture the big surprise on
video Lauren honey
we got cake and ice cream we got your
favorite and then chocolate chip
another time
Lauren are you okay
Lauren
I love mint chocolate chip
okay so Lauren is missing
Lauren is missing
and that's interesting also probably
important but mint chocolate chip is
favorite flavor
for Amanda not Lauren
woof
is that really something that you want
to say at this point is that really
appropriate right now I don't think so I
don't think so
all right the time was not important we
checked out that one
the date might not be important you know
what I probably gotta do uh I probably
gotta read those letters on the wall
over there
oh but I don't wanna
yeah Iris I already made that joke
oh
I don't think there's anything important
I don't think that there's anything
valuable here just wait a minute
I thought that would fast forward not
just skip yeah there probably wasn't
anything okay so at some point the real
Amanda
it's been three weeks since local
television producer Sam Colton was
reported missing and authorities still
have no leads
Colton is the creator of Amanda the
adventurer the public access children's
educational program that became a huge
hit among area children
but with Colton's disappearance the
future of the show remains unclear
last year Hamlin entertainment purchased
rights to the live action program
starring Colton's daughter Rebecca as
budget and production value increased
Hamlin reimagined the show as an
animated series planning to Syndicate
the program nationally
Hamlin's acquisition of the program and
Colton's recent disappearance have
raised some eyebrows so to further fuel
these concerns new episodes of Amanda
the adventurer have had subject matter
that has left local parents
uncomfortable about the program so we
have a bit into that show but it has
changed thank you Amanda was talking
about how mommies and daddies aren't
always right
I mean what is that well I mean true
it's not something you tell
impressionable kids I had to change the
channel I just told the kids that the TV
was acting up
it's not yet clear how Colton's
disappearance will affect the
involvement of his daughter Rebecca the
show's young star
we reached out to Hamlin entertainment
for an interview
while Representatives declined to
comment they did release a written
statement
we at Hamlin have concerns surrounding
the nature of Sam Colton's abandonment
of both our program and his daughter
we cannot speculate on his reasons for
leaving we do ask that the community
respect the privacy of Rebecca Colton as
she needs time out of the spotlight to
process these disturbing events
for the time being Rebecca's local
appearances have been canceled including
the kensdale public library fundraiser
woolley's readathon this Saturday
evening rest assured that Amanda is not
going anywhere Hamlin entertainment
remains committed to our vision for this
cherished program
despite the statement authorities have
not drawn any conclusions about the
nature of Sam Colton's disappearance
we will share any future updates as the
story develops
when we return we'll check in with zappo
The Talking gerbil
[Music]
so there's some dissonance here right so
that's true your friend Skip and with me
as always is my trusty Dog chip
so we have some dissonance here as I
finally am able to talk
we have
Sam Colton and his daughter Rebecca
Colton who plays Amanda and I'm curious
if there's something about that
connection that is not obvious all right
I'm gonna read these finally Dear Miss
Park I know it's been a long time since
you've seen me I swear
I swear the library was sometimes the
only place I felt safe I'll always be
grateful to you for that for being
someone I knew I could trust I needed
that again to trust two years ago my
little brother Jordan disappeared just
poof gone my parents were never the same
and now they're gone too they didn't
they just didn't get over the grief it
broke their hearts and eventually killed
them
the police figured someone snatched
Jordan off the street there's some crazy
guy lured him away a freak occurrence
you know a regular old suburban tragedy
but I know there's something more to it
and I know you know it too I thought I
was alone nobody believed me when I
tried to bring it up but I heard about
the kind of research you do the kind
that normal people don't do I don't know
maybe it's just a rumor but here I am
school records behavioral complaints
make appointment
the energy energy transfer we see sigils
diakinesis
Catherine Park 93 really well done okay
he used to watch that show you know it
was really sweet at first I remember
that you used to tell families with
younger kids to watch it it was I don't
know wholesome I guess and then it just
got weird I'd find Jordan standing in
front of the TV like he was in a trance
and it was like that little girl was
talking to him she said some really
weird stuff I know most of the people
around who don't believe in the kind of
work you do not on not at the library
the other kind of work they just don't
want to face the truth that's something
really evil was here can we meet and
talk I don't want to write anymore I
feel like someone's watching me Joanne
cook
you know for all we know cocoa melon
could be this exact same thing and we
would never know because how many of you
out there are watching Coco melon on a
regular basis and yet who knows what's
inside those things it could be Amanda
the adventure type horrors of unknown
distinction but how would we ever know
we just wouldn't we would never know
ever so I've got I have three tapes
there's six spots apparently four tapes
I'm so I'm so right I am right thank you
for noticing so let's just go through
again
well I know we're missing some stuff
well
you see I thought that fast forwarded
uh
uh I forget what the question here is
uh that sounds delicious
today we're going to make an apple pie
first we need to cut the apples hmm do
you know what we can use to cut the
apples
uh
we can't use that uh-huh good job
oh
oh right
okay so if this is
which one was this one this one was the
family one what is a family
maybe this one is more born get out of
there
how do I get out of here
hurry up
thank you
probably something in here
hi friends I'm Amanda and I'm woolly
just made an animal sound he said bye
because he is a sheep can you make a
sound like a sheep
that's great you sound just like Willie
wow yeah
you sound just like me
right you needed the thunderstorm thing
but do I need that
I might need that did I do it right I
feel like I didn't do it right
no I did it right didn't I do it right I
think
I did it right I did
[Music]
oh
right
that's not where they are
don't you know what a chicken looks like
I want to go look at the chickens
Sweet let's go see the silly chickens
what a cute baby
having a family is nice I see a mommy
chicken and baby chickens and I see
I see a daddy chicken look at the
chickens do you know what the daddy is
called
oh God damn it
what did I tell you now I was real I was
literally going on that train of thought
I'm putting you all in time out I put
you're all going in timeout God I was
going down that what did I tell you I
told you look at me while I'm talking to
you
what did I tell you I told you let me
get there and what did you do what did
you do what did you do
you ruined it
you ruined it you ruined everything
you just had to be the center of
attention didn't you there's a time to
do it you just had to do it and look at
you look look I'm I'm look it's it's
gone
okay it's gone
because you couldn't control yourself
you happy
you happy now
it's gone
man of the adventure
can't believe you
I can't believe you do this to all of us
here who were enjoying this so much
it's just so unbelievably irresponsible
to to
I
can't even believe it
I can't believe it
how could you do this
this could you do this it's just like
I don't know
I just thought better of you guys I
thought I thought that you had more
self-control
I thought that you could
I don't know be trusted
I guess not
all right I'm going to bring it back but
you guys better be on your best behavior
I'm warning you
hey look at that wow cloakbrand.com why
don't you check out the new collection
technically it's available through the
description below man you know the best
spoiler in life is getting this great
stuff right here
so why don't you go check it out yeah
it's available right now for a very
limited amount of time uh so go they're
extremely comfortable I recommend these
pants and I am obviously wearing this
shirt or this shirt sorry and I never
mind it's sold out
um
good this one's available
anyway uh so check it out it's now
available
um
thank you for being here
enjoying it and enjoying it
really great
all right I'm going back to it yeah I
was actually going down I was literally
I was literally thinking of this exact
same thing get get out of my face get
out of my face
now get out of my face get out of my
face
I was literally thinking this exact same
thing because there was something
strange about the way that Amanda said
well everything everything there
all right
uh
[Music]
should we go next
I think it's time to visit the sheep can
you tell me where we can find the Sheep
okay well what was the point of that
then
there was nothing to be done there that
didn't do anything wait did it do
something wait
oh
I'll put you right there for now okay so
I did that with my big brain you guys
had nothing to do with that that was all
me all the time
so don't even worry about being anything
other than just
uh
uh I don't want to see those they're
scary uh I don't want to go near
oh wait did I already I missed it it
doesn't matter I don't need another one
do I
I don't need another one
yeah I know I messed that up okay that's
fine
because I think I already did that I'm
pretty sure unless I mess it up there
uh uh
the Sheep are waiting for us
okay let's go look at the nice sheep
family all the Sheep are right where
they belong they sure are
I mean Willie looks happy so
I don't think a blizzard would do
anything
I don't think it Blizzard's even
possible
[Music]
what
wait
I don't know what the question is
uh
uh uh
yep
oh God uh what was there
God damn you did you're doing it again
you're doing just because I didn't even
hear the prompt oh man I don't think the
answer is Daddy I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure that it's not that
I'm listen how fun is this if we all are
here and I don't even get to use my
brain I've I'm pretty sure the answer is
it is I'm almost 100 positive guys I I
am almost absolutely certain
that this is not
the answer is not Daddy I don't think
it's Mommy either I don't think it's
either of those
I don't I don't think it's either of
those
I don't think his ass
all right so it's a toss-up between
Daddy and alone and you know it's just
it's such a
it's such it's such a toss-up hold on we
really gotta think about this one guys
this is this is tricky we we can't be
too quick about this all right so um
uh
uh hold on a second
this is terrible here we go okay
okay so what I have here
is
hold on
okay
so what I have here is a spinner wheel
with
the choices are alone daddy and mommy
and whatever I do whatever it lands us
is what I'm gonna type in right what are
the odds
whoa oh it's alone oh I don't know
there's no way to know that how could
you know that this game just came out
you wouldn't know what it was it doesn't
make any sense that you would know the
answer beforehand all right okay oh
sorry you're right there's one other
answer here that I forgot to put in
of course oh no there's too many hell
hold on all right uh
I think we just gotta I can't have those
two colors by themselves so this is oh
why that's no
no stop
yeah okay
all right Perfect all right got it these
are all five letter words it could be
any of them Zappo must be one you're
right Zappo right okay so we got alone
daddy alone daddy mommy cloak Zappo
woolly I I think wooly nah wooly can't
uh
no I can't be woolly it can't be woolly
woolly I don't think wooly I don't know
about wooly a chica ah that might be it
but okay let's just go with this right
okay
this seems fair this is fair this is the
only way to move forward because if we
do anything else then you will have
ruined the experience and I can't have
that so we're gonna spin Satan I'm sure
all right boom
[Laughter]
well God damn it all right I guess this
we're gonna do alone and whatever this
is dumb this is dumb
um this is
stupid and dumb
all right hold on all right one second
will you help the lonely kitten
wait what was even the wait I thought
isn't that was that not like a big was
that nothing
you guys made the biggest stink in the
world about it being alone
as if it was like the biggest secret in
the lower unit
anyway I've already said no so I'm just
gonna say yes
oh
[Music]
well that's not good
fascinating
interesting all right that's only mildly
uncomfortable
oh well the doll's gone which is
interesting uh I'm not dead which is
even more interesting and I have this
green tape
so strange
[Music]
welcome to coffee break today I'm
talking with Sam Colton the creator of
the hit kids show Amanda the adventurer
and I have to say a fantastic studio
neighbor thanks for having me on the
show Sadie you're a pretty good Studio
neighbor yourself
I am going to gain 50 pounds if you keep
stocking the kitchen with those
delicious homemade cookies you can't
have a coffee break without cookies
Sam last year you started interesting
Amanda the adventurer right here in the
studio
the whole town loves it
did you even imagine that would be such
a big sensation honestly Sadie no it was
a total surprise
big idea and a little budget
I don't know if I know what you're
talking about
cats don't really care about that though
they see the heart
and boy does your show have a big heart
you know I really have to thank our
local librarian Miss Kate for being such
a champion of the project I think she's
talked about it at every single story
time
I think it's just so rare nowadays for
kids shows to be so much fun but also
really teach kids something isn't it
what inspired you to create Amanda
I wanted to create a show that teaches
children that our world is a magical
place that there are Little Adventures
waiting around every corner in their
very own neighborhood the show is a
celebration of kids imaginations
but really
it's all Rebecca
as soon as I met my beautiful daughter
the inspiration was there
you know she was so young when I adopted
her and despite what she's gone through
she's always seen the world with such
kindness and joy
she's the light of my life and it makes
me so happy to share that light with our
community she really is something
special watching her perform is simply
delightful I mean the whole show is just
so cute thank you Sadie do you see big
things happening with Amanda the
adventurer I've actually had some people
approach me about it they want to turn
Amanda into a cartoon
I can't really talk about it yet but
it's exciting
it feels like a dream the idea of
welcoming even more kids into this wild
creative world
it feels like my little show could
really have a big impact
Sam
for having a coffee break with me today
our community is so lucky to have you
and Rebecca
on our next coffee break floral
arrangements for All Occasions featuring
the newest addition to our neighborhood
Rose Matthews of rose's bouquet
until then may your coffee always be
steaming and the conversation sparkling
[Music]
together
yeah all right
okay all right good uh well that was fun
I don't know what lore I got out of it
other than that
almost there
all right
nope
almost
gone
almost had that one
ah that's not quite even
drop that one
oh that's weird
should be right there oh no it's going
up
maybe it's because I'm not straightened
nope drop that one
Butterfingers
no
oh
so close I keep doing that
damn
no
oh right there
that's so close
I wonder if I fling it you
yep
wow how do I throw it backwards
that was kind of fun
yeah
oh it's kind of off the edge a little
bit
there
ah
sorry
[Laughter]
anyway what's going on what have we
missed I've totally forgotten what I was
doing what was I supposed to do so this
didn't blow up because I didn't do it
right uh but I don't think it matters
does it
um isn't it supposed to give me like
another
I don't know like another
Heap or something like that maybe I need
to go back to in the kitchen
because I didn't actually do what it's
said to do
uh I oh uh uh uh
what's my favorite type of pie
uh
meaty
[Music]
delicious
uh spear we can't use that could use
that
good job
and then pantry
wake up make a pie okay and then it's
gonna let's make a pie and then I'm
gonna turn around there's a pie making
thing so if I do the
if I do them
[Music]
let's see if I make uh
uh
uh there you go again
there you go again
ruining everything there you go again as
you think hold on come here you can wait
hold on I gotta make this more you see
that spear behind me I'm gonna use this
on you
I wasn't here you little
that actually looks that's pretty
authentic
I'm gonna tell you something about
something let me let me tell you
something about something you need to
look down here
don't look away
let me tell you something if you spoil
another thing for me again I'm gonna
force you to go to cloakbrand.com and
check out the latest drop there link is
in the description I swear if you ruin
this for me again I'm Gonna Make You
Suffer like you've never even believed
get the get out of here get
get out of here is that better
see that
let me use them on let me use it someone
said this was a paddle someone asked
like what this was I forgot that it's
theirs for a distractible thing I
brought it out for some reason
but
but uh uh that's it's not a paddle it's
a boar spear
obviously
it's a spear for boars
clearly
dummy
okay all right whatever
um
so anyway you guys I had this idea I
just thought of this if I if if I'm
asked
if I'm asked what type of
pie do I like I was kind of right in my
genius with the the meat pie because
there are meat pies but I just thought
about it what if
what if I put in a specific type of meat
pie that pertained perhaps to woolly
there
because Wooly's a sheep right so you
can't just put sheep meat in there that
wouldn't even fit but if you know your
English like I know my English and if
you have a big brain like I do you know
the sheep meat
is called leg of laughs that sounds
delicious
today we're going to make an apple pie
first we need to cut the apples hmm
good job
I thought it was great
oh wait no
I'm an idiot
leg of lamb is the type of meat when a
sheep is just a baby
that's a lamb
but in reality
it's looking for lamb chops oh that
sounds delicious today we're going to
make an apple pie first we need to cut
the apples hmm do you know what we can
use to cut the apples
I'm pretty smart
I'm really smart guys I'm really really
smart I'm really smart guys uh anyway
I'm gonna make a apple pie
I bet you guys didn't expect that would
work huh well I'm really
art
guys I don't know if you knew this but I
am like unbelievably smart
anyway let's Big Bob
so in your neighborhood
I'm just thinking that there's got to be
something that I'm missing
because the first thing is Corner Store
of course why wouldn't it be good job
good job thanks I've already done that
do you think that's what they need
huh
what do you say when someone helps you
great I found the perfect card time for
the next Aaron when friends do nice
things it's important to thank them I
want to get my friend a special treat
can I
dub let's go get that tree
[Music]
oh
I don't
I can't
I bought the cookies
[Music]
those looks
oh
I had an idea
I have an idea I have an idea right okay
I'm very smart
I'm very smart and now if I think of my
idea if I think of my idea my idea my
idea I'm putting in
okay
great great work now we can send this
[Music]
well what did that do what did that do I
don't know what that did I didn't do
anything
[Music]
well that didn't do anything
okay
[Music]
why does this sound weird
oh
[Music]
all right
whatever oh no accidents
have I
open that one I have haven't I
uh
oh uh
uh what that part of Willie looks fine
that's right Lily hurt his knee
oh foreign
[Music]
uh-huh
that's fine now we can look at Willy's
bones
uh oh accidents
[Music]
well didn't that
didn't that go somewhere else didn't
something else wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute what is this hey
[Laughter]
you know what I did but I did it
Rebecca that was great let's move on to
the next one
uh yeah
[Music]
Thailand
bye lamb what is this
what is she reading just a few simple
words this script is specifically tuned
to train the Technology's Dynamic voice
reaction the what
I want this to stop
why don't you take a walk for a few
minutes
we've only got a few more of these I
don't like to do that Rebecca what's
wrong who are you talking to the
Maryland
[Music]
this new man
she's upset this is going too far that's
what's inside
Rebecca come on out and uh
so was uh she reading some kind of a
demonic ritual that was going to possess
her soul and get her permanently stuck
inside of a cartoon
[Music]
I'm so close oh right there
all right okay just three more
okay so there's probably judging by the
bookshelf one more tape somewhere hidden
oh God I actually don't know how to get
that one there
well that's not good
well that's unacceptable
there we go so there's one more tape
somewhere we've got what's in a family
oh no accidents uh
I oh I don't remember
were you 345
345 I think it was 3 45.
there's only five that's impossible
there can't be only five what are you
dumb there's six slots in the Shelf are
you kidding me you're trying to tell me
that there are only five you are telling
me that they're only five when there are
clearly six slots on the Shelf there
listen I'm sorry I don't know what you
guys have been told you may have been
looking at some bad lore channels uh
because my big deducing brain says that
there's six and obviously there are six
you guys are so funny sometimes except
when you're so very wrong
there's clearly a six one and in this
stream we're gonna find it
we are absolutely going to find it
because no one is smarter than us
together
we are better than everybody else
and all those who think that there isn't
just so very wrong
go very wrong what was the last uh time
was the last time on 845 was that it 8
no
10 50. uh
uh it's not I don't know what you guys
are it's clearly not 10.50.
guys
5 15
.
the coolness on a sass clock
[Music]
all right so that says 826 but I already
opened that and I didn't get anything
out of it
then what was it what was this
[Music]
I have no memory of this lock
what was this one
creepy
okay
so this one had the bucket
and then you pour the bucket on blab bot
blab bot may love me but blab bot
doesn't pay the bills so I don't care
about blab bot
I thought we I am begging you
please
I love you
with you
you direct me give me another chance not
always
mercy on me
I will do anything please
I will show you number combinations
you've never even
from now late
I am begging you too late
[Music]
well I have this now and I have that so
Life's good
well what if I put bloodbot on you
okay what if I what oh
am I a genius or am I a goddamn genius
well I didn't do what I thought it would
do
you go there where you can collect water
for the rest of your days
you just uh you collect water there
buddy can I Chuck you on there all right
hold on I can figure this out
oh damn it okay hold on it's gonna be
worth it it's gonna be so worth it
all of my skills and practice have led
me to this moment
though all right whatever I don't know
why I can carry around these heads uh
it's really strange but maybe I could
make a pie out of them at some point
that would be nice that'd be nice anyway
I'm just gonna
display them here for all to see and I
don't know why that's still ringing but
it is
oh
trying to make it so it doesn't roll I'm
trying to get it to display properly
foreign
bot right here
and now I have the decapitated heads of
all my former friends isn't that sad all
right we need the key for this thing
now I have this and then there's this
and then we can share
I don't remember this one dude I do this
one
did I do this one
[Music]
hi I'm
Amanda
when you're friends you can share all
kinds of things with each other
I can share my crayons with you so you
can have fun coloring too where did
wooly go I don't know where wooly went
well he's gone
yeah sharing shows you care about
someone
friends can share toys
they can share snacks uh-huh I'll share
some of my snacks with you which snack
would you like
right
I'll take this note that's my favorite
friends can share other
s they can share secrets
can I share a secret with you
no
no oh
I thought you were different
[Laughter]
oh
oh no
oh no my types my hands uh leave why do
I still hear the goddamn clock
Google oh
oh
I don't know what I did
I didn't do anything
do you think that I did something I
didn't do anything
I picked your favorite food
I don't want to hear no secrets
we're not that close
it's kind of kind of gaslighting me you
know oh I'm a bad person because I don't
want to Bear your secrets well
oh God
I did I didn't do anything I didn't do
anything I think that it was actually
you guys that did that I think you put
that word in my head okay
I think that you did that I think that
you were trying to spoil the game again
and then you just changed up the script
and you ruined everything I think it's
your fault huh I think it's your fault
okay hold on hold on everybody
oh no
I got the sad ending
Oh no I got that sad ending
oh I got the boohoo ending
all right well if we want to unlock the
final ending
what I think has to be done
is we all have to go to cloakbrand.com
and check out uh the newest collection
uh that is going to be available for
only a limited amount of time or so I'm
hearing uh my big brain is telling me
thusly uh so definitely definitely
go check the link in the description
below it is very true it's very true
okay
there's
there's a meat ending
there's two two endings left where
there's one tape left that's for sure
everybody knows that there's one tape
left and apparently
did
did anybody else just see that
am I am I crazy
what was that
what you also you all saw that
you know usually when I'm not live
streaming and I'm just recording games
I'll see something and I'll be like what
in the hell was that
and I think I'm crazy
and it's like so they do actually put
in this game that
is not
I'm not crazy is what I'm saying okay
whatever
it was a mouse yeah sure keep telling
yourself that I'm sure oh yeah it was a
mouse uh 100 it was a mouse it sure did
it it definitely didn't you
uh
oh you wanna know a funny story
oh
it's a boar spear that's not the funny
story
someone just said look behind me
so I looked behind me and I remembered
that that was there
it's not a battle it's a bore spear it's
a bore spear to spear for bars
ooh pour water on the TV that's a good
idea oh
can I just pour this on anything
that's a pretty good idea
yeah
that is an effective sploosh
how is that not
well
one drop is all
it's quite a robust
you can trust me
[Music]
damn it
huh
pour it on the robot oh
oh oh oh
guys we figured it out
put it on the robot
[Music]
wait a minute
we've NE we've never done anything with
this
foreign
or was this the one that needed 10.50 we
did do something with this we did do
something with this we did we did we did
we did we did oh yeah oh blab box dad oh
oh
no
oh oh God
no no
oh why did you kill me
wait okay
look at his decapitated head look at his
decapitated head you get nice yoga dance
got it all right C is fine this is it's
just
his head but you know it's there okay
all right whatever anyway we need a key
this isn't
got this mice
those Meister quick them some quick
mises all right so I think
obviously we're missing something
and then we
need to go here and then say yes
right the story
I'll tell in a second
yum that's my favorite oh
friends can share all right yes are you
sure
is it really
I'm out there huh
somewhere uh-huh
[Music]
okay we did this one
take take
what happens if I just let it go
[Music]
thank you
wow
foreign
[Music]
who is that
hat ending
who what I don't know
this is the part where you're supposed
to tell me who that was
yeah man pretty much
there's the TF2 Pyro
[Music]
write the story okay in a second in a
second how
where's that at we got the Hat ending
okay so I think there's another ending
right
there's another ending
it was Among Us
it was mongers
it was longest more strongest okay so
there's probably
uh uh
girl man
um
did I actually go down the whole path
with
um the right uh
that sounds delicious today I know I
haven't gotten first we need to I
haven't gotten all that I'll get to the
story in just a second you know but we
can use to cut the Apple
okay so if I go here and then I burn
everything
hmm
I've done this before what if I get the
bucket of water and I sploosh it on him
now that's thinking
now that's thinking I'll put that fire
right out
ah where's the shot
[Music]
all right well they're panicking don't
know why right and then the cheese thing
uh
uh okay 525
so this has got to be going towards the
meat ending right
so potato mushroom
meat it's obviously with this
watch out
meat
is it am I going towards something
that's actually a thing or are you all
just deceiving me
is the meat ending for realsies
is the neat ending for reels
potato
it is yes okay then it's gotta be down
this path right I think I might have
goofed it uh somewhere here
uh along the way
so meat potato mushroom
[Music]
so because this is a meat pie right this
is meat pie which means that it must be
something uh
50 minutes
meat is real yes meat is real
all right the story of course so um it's
not really a story you remember how in
the last one I was talking so much about
how like I was so glad that when I uh I
got my new prescription for a stars that
it was a much smoother process for my
ADHD medications and it was like totally
fine and I looked uh uh up everything
and it was like oh man insurance was Go
cover and everything and it was like so
smooth and it was like gonna be able to
get the same day when I said that I had
not picked it up yet because I looked
after I got the prescription sent it in
and I looked at my phone and I was like
oh it's great estimated cost zero
dollars oh man it's in progress this is
gonna be fantastic and I was so happy
about that and then later that day I
called up the the the pharmacy hey is it
ready to pick up again uh and they're
like uh what medications they offer four
stars and then uh they were like oh yeah
your insurance need a prior
authorization
and I said what
and it's not that I don't know what a
prior authorization is
I know what a prior authorization is
because I got a prior authorization for
this
for this medication
and I it's all fine because as soon as I
got that I got the prescription no
problem but it was just like it
flabbergasted me because I was like why
is why is it not uh there and they said
oh because the prior authorization
expired
and I said what
how could that happen
what change how do you know something
changed in my life that it's no longer
authorized and I'm just like if it was
needed a while ago why is there a time
limit on the me need it paper on the
paper that says me need it why must
there be a time limit
how I don't I think it's all just one
big scam to make you go through one
extra hoop because they know that having
this stupid prior authorization thing is
gonna cause that one percent of people
to take the extra time or not take the
extra time and not do it and either they
don't have to pay for the medication or
they pay for it themselves
the prior authorization is the doctor
saying this prescription is necessary
when he signs the prescription that's
him authorizing it or her
anyway that's my little rant about it
once I got that it was fine and all the
stocking issues for the prescription
have been gone away I got it right away
but it it just made me so mad
unnecessarily at Insurance again and I
just was so angry because I was so happy
I was so happy that morning that it was
like oh I could get this like you you
guys know I talked about this last year
where I was like this prescription I
want it but it's a nightmare to get
because no one got it and so they didn't
stock it and there was that whole issue
but now it's in stock people have it and
it's just like it's available at all my
local pharmacies and it's still dull are
you sure you need it I didn't make sense
my doctor said that I don't make the
decisions uh anyway
anyway sorry that's so like I said it's
not a story it's just another thing
together
God all right
hi there I'm Amanda and I'm Lily
Amanda maybe some of our friends can
come back to the neighborhood
I like that there are so many be friends
in my neighborhood
today okay I want to send something
special to my friend how I need to go
together
[Music]
know where the store is
meat flower pot
wait what do you mean
what mean you
what do you mean
what do you mean all right this is where
I'm actually gonna get some help on this
okay there's a meat people are saying
there's a meat flower pot
this meat flower pot
oh wait a minute
well you're probably saying
is that there's more pots here than
there are symbols is that what you're
saying is that what you're getting it
and so one of these is not actually
on here one two three four five six ten
so there's ten of these
so if there's more than 10 pots that
means okay one two three four five six
seven
well that wasn't the number I was
expecting uh
what
how does that make sense why are there
only seven
that's a missing some are missing
pot wait no this is just
that's just that one
no that's not the one
so there's a meat pot there's no meat
pot I don't believe you I believe that
there's a meat pot there's definitely a
meat pot right yes exactly
it was almost too easy so if I lay all
the pots in a neat little row then I'm
going to see the truth for what it is
and all those non-believers who thought
that I was so silly so stupid are going
to realize that it is they who are truly
lost and also stupid and dumb and ugly
yes it's true it is extremely very true
s so if we discount the one pot that I
know I already used because I made a
potato out of it then we are left with
eight pots which means that one pot is
missing so where is said pot all right
yes it's all coming together the last
pod must be the meat pot count them one
two three four five six seven eight okay
get that in your brain and count these
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten right minus one potato that
leaves nine plus one plus two minus one
potato plus two potato that means nine
there's one missing it's the meat flower
yes it's gotta be here somewhere there's
oh
it can only be unlocked by by blooming
all of the flowers yes of course I am a
genius I am absolutely so smart by
getting all of the flowers blooming and
blossoming yes then the secret will be
unlocked
wow fun
okay yes this is it this is the truth
now we're on track all those naysayers
and non-believers how stupid do you feel
now you don't even understand what
you're doing I am the only one that
understands anything that's going on in
this game everyone is just so beneath me
in terms of lore exploration this is why
I am the king of Amanda the adventurer
no one else can claim that Throne
because I already just claimed it matpat
get I am now in charge I don't
care what anybody says I'm unlocking
secrets that even the developer of this
game never even imagined could be done
yes and I am the true truest truest king
of amend the adventurer watch as I
unlock all of these
all of the Seekers that people wish they
knew uh they don't know but I know and I
know I know because I know watch the
power that will be
brought forth the moment that I Blossom
all of these flowers
there is a meat pot I swear it I swear
upon all that I know that there is a
meat pot
or I'm not the king of Amanda the
adventurer
beautiful
truly something remarkable is happening
here
truly something special
I've done it
I don't have room for this last one
good enough
beautiful
somewhat asymmetrical but it's by Design
alright so where is the meat pot
there is no meat pot it's the meat pot
there's a meat pot I know there's a meat
pot there's a pot that when you put it
under the water it's gonna grow meat
there cannot not be a meat pot
there is definitely a meat pot okay
there is we can all make it all
we can all agree we can all agree yes we
can all agree
I know we can because I say we can okay
what am I doing here someone please tell
me what the hell I have to do
flower ending
meet I don't need to go there right now
do you think this is funny
just take me to the store
now can you tell me where I need to go
me to meet is the answer
meet meat
that's not the right card
we want this I think Amanda is confused
here's a secret
it's my birthday maybe we can help her
out
go ahead and pick a card friend
uh are you sure that's right I don't
like it
meat they don't have anything we need
meat look at the stores which one sells
candy meat ah does this help
great Lush why did you do that now I
can't find this candy store
help me
meat
I said I don't want to go in there meet
[Music]
meat
I don't know meat
candy store was that sound
that's fine
so the answer
oh I think there is
no we're in the right place
what meat meat
delicious meat meaty meat meat I want to
get my friend a special treat meat let
me out of here oh Amanda that's that's a
nice birthday card do you want to give
it to your friend now
will you address the card who should I
send this to
ah meat wait is this important wait hold
on a second
all right
hold on
oh
wait
I'm thinking carefully
all right it doesn't matter no it
matters
it matters
yes
Riley I don't think it's their birthday
fine
Lily it's your birthday
what in the what in the ass what do you
mean there was no meat option
there was no
there was no meat option guys guys
you're telling me that I went through
all that for nothing there was no meat
option
is yeah
no
my flowers
where did my flowers go
oh there they are that's lovely okay
that's nice
all right anyway
so the meat ending exists we all know
that the meat ending exists we know this
we know this
uh-huh
we went
toe the meat
guts I already have done this I've done
this a thousand times
no no no no no
I've already done this because the
the doll is gone
I've already done it I've duned it
I've done the giving of the flower
there's a meat ending and I'm
Adam where's the meat
what is a family I don't really know
what a family is
hi friends I'm Amanda and I'm woolly
just made an animal sound he said bye
because he is a sheep because he he is a
sheep oh yeah he's a sheep
uh all right I've already done that
the daddy is called I've done that
okay let's go look at the nuts
uh alone
yes
[Music]
I need to go
so close did I miss it I didn't miss it
am I am I close wait hold on
did I miss the meat ending
did I miss the meeting I've already done
that
welcome to half an hour ago you're late
I already did the Sam thing I already
did that that's already been done that
ain't the meat ending that ain't meat
that's not meat you want tell me what
Mead is all about that ain't meat
no
no no you're not gonna tell you're not
gonna sit there and tell me that you
know what the meat ending is because
I don't think you understand how vital
the meat ending is to this game I
you wish you knew what the meat ending
was all about you don't
oh my goodness you've done that
oh well more your loss more my game
uh I hope someday you don't live in
ignorance
so your aunt died The Joy of Cooking
sheep
glow glow flocks the Untold Story
am I being
full
[Music]
and autobiography
in
inquisitive Ian discovers tax fraud
hey wait a minute
hey wait a minute what is that bottom
one that looks like some kind of a code
hey wait a minute guess who's a genius
hey all right okay
hold on
okay look at this
what does that look like to you is that
a code is that a code huh here let me
let me uh hold on one second
if I
hold on
so we got the joy of cooking
we've got so you're oh let me actually I
can I can change this
uh flip vertical Okay so we've got
oh I need to flip Horizon there we go
we've got the joy of cooking sheep
hold on hold on
we've got the joy of cooking sheep so
your aunt died
Justin Cinema glow foxy untold story am
I being followed an autobiography
inquisitive he didn't discover snapdrod
and this
what is this ah
yeah
that's what I thought
that right there is code and a code
that's gonna lead us right to the meat
ending
right right right
there's some meat ending in here
this is the secret that everyone has
overlooked this is this is the secret
that no one has been able to find except
for me
this is where it all comes together
and I
I have I've deciphered it
in my head
I've deciphered it I have it's true
I can hardly believe in myself but I
have
because he used this very special
website
that allows me
to see what the truth is
and I don't think you guys are going to
be the same after I read to you what
this actually says because
like it blew my mind with how incredible
it is okay if you look at the first
grouping
it says who is Cloak oh
cloakbrand.com available through the
link in the description below new drop
available right now wow that is
astonishing and there's an error on here
they they made an error on the website
oh man I'm having so much fun look at me
you too can go to cloakbrand.com and you
can you can have yourself a wonderful
time and just dance the night away in
the latest drop brought to you by cloak
brand I can't even believe how much fun
I'm having through the link in the
description below with the latest drop
oh man it it practically was designed by
me I mean even though you might read
something that says it was designed by
someone else who's definitely not the
CEO it still might as well have been
designed by me because of how much I am
the CEO of this company
oh we have fun here oh God what a great
time Link in the description below
oh
anyway
all right no one will ever solve what
this is
no one will ever know and certain least
of all me uh but that's a that's a
puzzle for the ages
what was I doing I've completely
forgotten
I have no idea
uh
meat ending meet ending
I know there's a meat ending
meat ending meet ending meet meat ending
and meat ending meet ending meet ending
meet ending
I know there's a meat ending meet ending
meet ending mid ending meet ending
meet ending meet ending
10 thing I have meat ending meet ending
meet emptying meat ending meet ending
meet and ding
beat and meat ending
what
wait
wait a minute
wait wait wait a minute wait a minute I
know I got it wait a minute
wait for it
wait for it wait
a minute
I know how to get it
wait yes of course wait a minute no wait
no not this hold on
keep waiting ah hold on right up hold on
hold on
there's nobody
no I won't I won't I won't I won't hold
on
[Music]
[Applause]
nope
oh
[Music]
okay
all right
all right listen no no hold on no hold
on hold on no that wasn't it you all are
you don't even understand you you don't
you don't under hold on one second
hold on
oh
right
I got it I got I got it I got it hold on
never I I will hold on
[Music]
hmm
hold on I got this i got this wait
I ruined it
wait I ruined it hold on hold on
hold on wait I got this hold on I have
this I know exactly what to do genuine
question am I okay absolutely
I know exactly
thanks
I know what to do yeah I I got this you
you think
I got this the meat ending is mine
the meat ending has been had
Get Ready Get Ready
[Music]
I got this i got this guys don't worry
about a thing
the meat ending
yes
how did I know I'm just that good
oh yes
no no no no no no no no no you all are
doubting me you're doubting my abilities
right now and I don't need any of that I
know exactly what I'm up to okay watch
this
oh oh wait hold on okay well
[Music]
hold on you guys are still doubting my
abilities because I know exactly what
needs to be done to get the meat ending
trust me
oops oh God
oh God
oh no that was horrible okay hold on
kids in there
all right I got it
okay
this is fine
I know I'd uh let him cook I don't think
you should let me cook on this one good
that's not the right card
hold on hold on hold on
I already have this wait this is the one
I need no no hold on hold on that's not
what it's about oh no
oh no
oh no oh no
this is not a joke this time why can't I
get this in
that
okay that's good enough
I don't think
great Lush why did you do I didn't do
anything
hold on
let me out of it
meat
y I don't think it's their birthday
ah mark
the card is for someone really cute oh
me me
I guess you actually forgot oh God wait
wait
oh Willy
okay but hold on hold on hold on
get ready for it
this is what it's all about this is what
it's all about
okay all right are you ready
yeah you're not ready
hold on
oh wait I keep forgetting that I don't
actually need to do that I can just jump
straight to this why am I wait did I not
need to do any of that hold on yes I did
the answer is absolutely I did but get
ready because I'm about to show you why
hold on
I definitely needed to do all that 100 I
needed to do that because let me show
you why
uh hold on
hold on
because what I need to do is I need to
be able to get
the thing hi friends
funny this that's not where they are
don't you know what a chick
I want to go look at the chickens
all right let's go see those silly
chickens what a cute wait did I miss it
already
did I miss it God
mommy chicken and baby chickens and I
see
I see it
but daddy is called a rooster
hold on hold on guys
hold on okay
hold on
hold on ah crap
put it right back in
this is what we do
this is how we make this happen this is
how we make the meat
friends I'm Amanda and I'm woolly
animal sound he said bye because he is a
sheep can you make a sound like a sheep
that's great you sound just like Willie
wow yeah you sound just like me
so for your thunderstorm warming
excellent
[Music]
I'm not gonna skip I'm not skipping
anything
I'm not skipping anything
I've got it
they are very different from people
they don't talk like people
Amanda
I'm an animal and I'm animals don't talk
silly
look at these signs
let's make sounds like the animals on
the signs
are you ready
a goat says
a chicken says
a pig says like
ten animals make funny sounds I've guys
I've done this before animals guys you
don't understand I have literally done
this before I've gotten the next tape
I've done it all I am so good at this
game you're trying
to be patronizing towards someone who is
literally the king of Amanda the
adventure the absolute King
of a man of the adventurer you don't
even understand how good I am okay
I'm so good at this I'm so good
I've done it before did I miss it
having a family is nice
I see a mommy chicken did I miss it any
chicken
s did I miss it
Dad look at the chickens do you know
what the daddy is called
wait did I miss it what did you say how
deep
where should we go next did I miss it I
think it's time to visit the Sheep
can you tell me where we can find the
Sheep
ew I don't want to see those they're
scary
[Music]
ah
oh it's all good it's all good guys it's
all good it's all good
it's all good guys
shush shush
hold on
guys I got this
guys it's fine hold on
I've got the meat ending no it's not
painful this is what it needs to be
oh
exactly
[Music]
you sound just like me there it is all
right so I got that but I'm already on
the next one it's okay go go cover out
again I got it I got it I got it
I got it
I got it I got it there's oh there's a
meat ending all right you guys don't
think that there's a meeting oh oh yeah
it's fun to spend time with animals they
are very different from people okay
oh I got this
so
[Music]
are you ready what I need to do
what I need to do definitely is
a pig says like
what I need to do
crew record
guys hold on just because why would I
leave this in if this was pre-recorded
why would I leave this in
okay
show me where the chickens are
hold on
wait a minute
that's not where they are
don't you know what a chicken looks like
I want to go look at the chickens
all right let's go see the silly
chickens what a cute baby
having a family
all right
no that's not what they're called try
okay it was actually much easier to get
through than I thought it was I didn't
need to do anything right of course that
makes a lot of sense
right yeah okay no no no it's fine guys
it's fine guys guys it's fine skip okay
wait what did you say no no it's fine
this is fine
it's really good no it's fine you can
Skip it's totally good it's totally good
it's totally good
it's it's all good see
you guys thought that you were so smart
but it turns out you're dumb and I'm
smart
ha
skip
okay skip alone okay
yes
[Music]
I've got it yes this is it now I've got
it now I have it
yes now is my time
yes
it's perfect
did I do it I did it right I did the
thing no I did the thing
I did it I did it yes hi hello
what's that smell
what do you think is making that bad
smell the
Willie
I think it's woolly
that looks fine I did it the meat Time
Is Here
[Music]
yes yes I am what is
no I did it I did the thing
I did the thing
[Music]
did I do this no no no
you guys don't understand
it's gonna be different
and it's gonna be different
dead
is
of alive I know
when an animal dies it rots too
it looks like this kid is in big trouble
it might die before anyone can help it
should we help the kitten
so
since this is the meat ending
what we need to do
is we need to not save it
because
then we can
turn it in the meat
and therefore
get the meat ending
right am I right
am I right I'm right that's how we I
actually
no I got a yes
so I gotta say
and
no no no no no I'm hearing a lot of no's
I'm hearing a lot of no's
so I say no
yes do I say no
say no if you don't want me to say no
I'm saying hearing a lot of no's
so no I say no
[Music]
much time time
oh oops
wait wait what impossible
no use it's impossible it's impossible
and no use
well this is sad
[Music]
you
thought it was a lie
you don't meet you all said that the
meat ending didn't exist you were wrong
you were wrong
that is the meat ending
that's the freaking meat ending
all of you said that it didn't exist it
was real it was 100 real
the meat ending Canon
absolutely real 100 real
very extremely real
100 real
I did it
that's what makes me
the king of Amanda the adventurer
[Music]
the greatest
you didn't say you existed you were all
doubting the meat ending was possible
you all doubted it you all said it
didn't exist all of you said it didn't
exist all of you every one of you all
right I think
is there one more
that's all of them right isn't that all
of them
yes there is
foreign
[Music]
right
that's all of them
ever yeah it's all of them
isn't that all of them haven't I done
all of them I've done all of them
haven't I no that's the whole of them
that's all definitely 100 right
but there is a sex tape
and I'm gonna show it to you
it exists
it does
a fifth tip
I've got it right here
you ready
cloakbrand.com
[Laughter]
cloakbrand.com where you can get the
latest collection ah you can dance with
all of us over at cloakbrand.com it's
got the secret six tape if you click the
link in the description the one that
says cloakbrand.com you can get the
secret the secret tape for yourself and
you too can be a part of this incredible
collection that you could
you could be closer than ever to the
secret sex tape yes absolutely the sixth
tape is going to be revealed at
cloakbrand.com the only place that you
can get it I made an exclusive deal with
the developer of this game to put the
secret sex tape at it buried in the
source code of cloakbrand.com so why
don't you go through the link in the
description below and only you can be a
part of the magical mystical secret sex
tape
yeah
all right listen listen
it's not an ad when I own the company
it's not an ad
okay that's how it works probably
definitely probably all right
um but actually there is a 16 100.
no joke sees
and uh
one second
ah one second
wow that's a lot of steps that I don't
want to do to get the secret sex tape uh
I'm gonna just
um let's see
no I've got it I've got it okay I've got
it
hold on
one second
[Music]
okay perfect perfect
got it okay
uh
all right cool
oh one second Oops why is that like that
sorry it's muted
why are you muted
unmute damn you
all right this is actually uh the secret
six tape I just couldn't be bothered to
hack it myself so I'm shamelessly
stealing it from bandan
okay all right now I know that blew your
minds
I knew that was beyond incredible but
what I'm going to tell you
is that there's actually one more tape
yeah pretty cool
um this one was even harder to find and
to be honest uh it's going to be a
pretty crazy experience
in roughly 40 seconds standby
um
closing maximum depth
uh the whole ceiling it but it's still
holding stronger
[Music]
signal
big and beautiful
[Music]
wow
I think it's actually uh uh extremely
Brave of them to put in a trailer for
the iron lung movie as the secret
seventh tape of uh Amanda the adventure
really bold decision of them
um but I'm gonna blow your gourd one
last time because there is
an eighth tape yes it's true it is
fantastically true it is one thousand
percent true there is an eighth tape and
it's like I am very proud of myself to
be able to bring this uh tape to you
because to make this tape uh like being
the first one not only to find it uh
but the first one to bring this to you
is just like it's something special that
I think that no one else
um could do except me and uh I'm just
I'm just happy to be here for the ride
foreign
lung the movie but in space with
markiplier the Emmy nominated uh YouTube
original show that is astonishingly
Brave however as incredibly Brave as
that eighth tape was there there is a
ninth secret tape
I can't hard I'm crying because it's so
beautiful when I unlock the ninth tape
there was
a nice tape
you would
you wouldn't believe what I found inside
it was the most beautiful thing
this one
this is
[Laughter]
I guess
if you look secret in the code of the
game
it's
um there was
oh man is is oh God damn it
this new video episodes of distractible
on Spotify
we're uploading twice a week now
so check it out they put
I think it's so brave of the developers
of a man of the adventure to put the
entire distractible catalog including
new video episodes
on Spotify so that you can see Bob Wade
and I as the secret tenth tape
[Laughter]
so our ninth tape
I got ahead of myself I started talking
about the 10th tape uh spoiler alert
there's another tape
thank you
I'm sorry it's just like it gets me
choked up thinking about the beauty of
it
ah
here it is
not only it could I think this one was
actually logical this one was very
logical one after the other to not I
mean I this one was a given not as
puzzling as ninth uh the ninth tape but
the tenth secret tape
was a link that led to go my favorite
sports team with Tyler uh the Ethan
shied and Mark E playor
and also has new video episodes and not
only that are gonna have very special
guests Tom Brady Maybe
and other people too
so get ready Ethan the nesters
all right sorry that's all the tapes
guys that there's no more tapes I I
don't know what you guys are expecting
10 tapes is just enough 10 tapes is more
than enough that's that's what it is
that's that's all that's all it could be
I don't know how you could possibly
think that there would be like your life
and on 11th tape has been found
cloakbrand.com go check out the link in
the description below for your
newest collection there's an 11th tape
the 11th tape has just dropped Link in
the description
oh my God
go to cloakbrand.com check out these new
incredibly fashionable and Incredibly
Comfort clothing today Comfort clothing
that's what it'll be when you get it
cloakbrand.com Link in the description
if you don't
I'll cry
I will cry
I'll cry what was the sixth day that was
it yeah the six tape actually was just
woolly it's it's if you hack into the
game you get the sex tape
so there you have it
anyway I'm gonna get out of here thank
you everybody so much for watching uh do
check out cloakbrand.com for the
collection there do check out
distractible do check out go my favorite
sports team I'm trying to be better
about all these updates and promotions
of things that I should be promoting and
I'm going to do that because I'm a good
YouTuber please somebody sponsor me
please see how good I am at selling
things I will use anybody I will use
anything to sell your product if you
give me a chance I I'm trying to get
some maybe like film equipment
um
uh money I'll take that that'd be great
uh sponsor me I will hawk your product I
look I've been blacklisted by Sour Patch
Kids by Taki so they won't even talk to
me they only have eyes for ninja and I
don't understand it
um no one likes stockies more than I do
uh and that is true until they broke my
heart but that's why I'm blacklisted
because I'm vengeful and I am an
extremely spiteful
um but please sponsor me
please I have nobody
dislike sponsored me I did I think I did
a good job with that one
all right cool anyway I'm gonna go
Link in the description
Del Monte also hates me